little a and then the ring around it at
sea that's what I said mm-hmm
taste said she thought it was about yeah
but I've never heard it around anyway
what are you right to it like mail
no a lot of people use it and
communicate it I guess it's becoming
really big now Allison can you explain
what internet is my name is Darren I'm
an investment banker and a mid 90s Wall
Street has finally got a new favorite
supermodel Silicon Valley one word
Netscape Netscape they have zero concept
of what Netscape is you don't even know
what the internet is
pixel on is number one the internet
broadcasting the globe calm it's a
social network people will want to log
on I guarantee it's very addictive okay
let me break it down for you in the
simplest of terms this is the beginning
of what they called the browser Wars
nesic is pumping wine we have a price
refresh your page 71 dollars a share or
you can make the biggest deals it's
Microsoft I'm gonna live in things up a
little bit
people are even throwing money at us we
are gonna be very wealthy and very
famous we are the top browser in the
business congratulations
it also makes us a target Microsoft owns
the Internet did they just threaten
I'm gonna bring in a couple of experts
Netscape change the game you Microsoft
University we were the new kid on the
block who were death-bed competitors
so that happened
we're out of money what about the
technology I created god damn it
keep the fame pixel on was a joke we
have 90 percent of the browser market
thus got Microsoft's bringing down their
neck good tuck
I created something that you all now use
everyday you're welcome
get big fast was for the mantra we are
running a billion-dollar company and
wanted to take it on the train even
though they didn't know where the train
was going people are hoping for better
tomorrow and that's what we are selling
please keep it up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]